Gennady golovkin who joins us here in
the man cave how are you look good you
look like you're ready to own that it
you are ready to fight somebody right
absolutely
you have your translator here but you
don't need your translator you have
great English I think now you're doing
this you got a fight on Saturday right
shouldn't you be like in hiding and like
getting ready for it you're going to the
Rangers game tonight absolutely Rangers
game you know because here I follow
arrangers team myself he's huge friends
around Jersey not just I like it I want
a first game I want to watch
woody what is it about hockey you love
you know I like everybody's different
everybody everybody seems different
different politics you know just I love
with the game I love it sport how good a
hockey player would you be sometimes I
play my I remember my school time not
right now just so dangerous you know
just my choose company said no but you
could fight on the ice - no no I'm not
some guy no you're not you know Crosby
McDade like you know you'd be Sidney
Crosby yeah of course you know like you
know Sidney Crosby like last time last
season you know Nicky the culture of his
Russian guy he show off
yeah he looks good now you have this
pleasant personality smile on your face
like when when does your personality
change on fight night
you know you feel sometimes if you come
into ring you know right now okay right
now it's triple G time you know so
dangerous so serious so different
completely different you know just you
know your job you know this is dangerous
porting all these dangerous business
because you I remember just seriously
for me just one punch change life you
know not change fight change life you
know this whole but do you have to
dislike your opponent does it help no
you know just I right now I know my
opponent just I respect him because I
know him a long time I
no he has had good strong team good
experience he have good experience from
amateur or last couple fights you know
he's professional Atlas but also you can
sometimes get too aggressive or I want
to kill you I mean not kill you I want
to hurt you and then you get out of your
style like have you ever found yourself
to be like so angry that you fight
differently than you probably should be
no you know just if you know how you
know just sometimes I need more for me
for me more important like time timing
if I see like body language he's not
ready I wanna eating no I wanna kill him
like like that like like a predator you
know like like that but I I wonder about
that though when you get in like later
in the rounds like are you a better
boxer later in a fight than you are
earlier in a fight probably yes because
you know well it's I am like you know
just I know he's I feel him just a
little bit speed is down you know like
everything I heard him out
yes then yeah I think so yeah like you
know just second half just like I have
just you know who's better like you know
boxing khaki or high quality boxing is
more important what's the perfect punch
feel like maybe but what's it's late /
what's it feel like
like when you land that perfect punch
like a shoot you know like a boob oh
yeah like that like it explodes
yes exactly have you ever felt sorry for
an opponent oh it's so tough it's not
gonna end well for this guy exactly yeah
the zone of is gonna be carrying this
that'll be at Madison Square Garden so
triple G now do you go do you like to be
called triple G absolutely because I
thought the media started calling you
triple G because they couldn't pronounce
your name no right now my fight week
just you know like my focus hard part's
into boxing if I stay in boxing I just
have I like topology you know I go home
just my family
I stay like a Gennady like the family
doesn't call you trabocchi Oh Noah yeah
no but I think it's and give us the
correct pronunciation of your name first
and last name ID golovkin okay because
I've heard it different ways
you probably heard people pronounce it
differently every time is different
everybody's different but you're okay
with that yeah of course thank you know
just probably what did you think when
Floyd Mayweather fought Conor McGregor
it's good business deal you know just
this is not box it's not you see like
two sports it's kind of this come on
this show this great show this is boxing
would you would you fight Conor McGregor
would you box him absolutely if you have
the same body but did you see anything
with cotton what if it was UFC is
different I'll just if I cover to UFC
and always be present to Conor if I call
it a comment so box and can all this big
if for me how do you know somebody can
fight by just looking at them can you
sometimes like if somebody walks down
because you know he's of course yeah
like not just his muscles or something
you know just his position he's timing
he's distance you know just a lot of
growing up where you grew up
who are your idols in boxing or like who
got you I know your brothers were big in
the sport but yeah but was there a
professional boxer where you said I want
to be like him are these because every
seriously everybody like different like
hey wait like
Mike Tyson Muhammad Ali no just oh okay
my child like all school you know like
they said like I mean the revision
everybody's different softball right
like Marvin Hagler his softball you know
like sugar Ileana he's oh like our Roy
Jones he looks good so many so many
people guys have you met Tyson Sugar Ray
Leonard absolutely yeah what was that
like it looks good you know just write
this in boxing convention like show TV
like you know for this situation like
for a regular life everybody looks good
could you take a punch from Tyson no I
was always fascinated with Sugar Ray
Leonard yes
because he had the ability to go
toe-to-toe and punch but then he was so
like we look at Floyd Mayweather
I think Sugar Ray was Floyd Mayweather
but he had more punching power does that
make absolute sense yeah yeah you know
just different time different gloves
different area you know like her right
now boxing will bring more power more
you know more dangerous stuff do you
want to get bigger night I mean you're
37 now do you go up in weight class at
all you care to you know I feel very
comfortable in 160 in the middleweight
division just Eve I have like big
business plan or big name of course I do
but Canelo can are we gonna do that one
more time
sure we are of course cuz I thought you
got robbed when you fought him I'm sure
you did too
but how much do you think about that
fight yeah right now I had great
experience from boxing this is boxing
business sometimes it's crazy
yes I know harmful sense I agree this is
box yeah but when they held up his hand
like what did you think when you're like
what's that feeling like I can't believe
it just you know just you know I'm
serious guys this is boxing right now
like that you know just oh this is
horrible
not for me for sport you know just I
want to bring boxing position right back
right now we'll lose you know these
people killed boxing well I think that
that you to help bring back boxing
because you know UFC was getting all the
headlines and I think when they we
watched you too all of a sudden it was
like you know because we grew up with
these rivalries when Hagler and Hearns
or Sugar Ray Leonard or Roberto Duran
and you know Carlos Monzon and I mean
there was so many great fighters didn't
have to be heavyweights
but this is what you guys are reminding
me of what it used to be like 30 years
ago
absolutely I want to bring out all
school in law not just business
and these people are that's the bad part
of boxing absolutely yeah because if you
get in the ring and we took everybody
out in you to just fought yeah if you
come a to ring you know just like my
situation if I go into ring I know just
I need just knock out if not be bring
Nicole just 99 percent I lose this fight
yes it's horrible it's horrible
well I hope you get a chance to fight
him again okay yeah I hope so
yeah you're not afraid of it I can't
right now because you know he is job
he's waiting all last time last
September we'll have a contract we have
everything he said no I don't know why
is he afraid of you I don't know he
might be afraid of you
maybe I hate you not right now not yet
that may be maybe like to Slater
wait you gotta wait to your 39 or 40 no
I don't want to wait just oh I know he
called me I say like grandfather he said
what what if you fight him like on
Sunday so you fight Saturday night yes
and then if Canelo said let's fight on
Sunday would you do that yeah well you
got to be crazy to get in the ring in
the first place right you're right yeah
you can download to zone D AZN that app
if you can't go to the garden so the
fight is coming up Saturday night at
Madison Square Garden and one of the
best schedules in boxing history the
only place to watch triple G so we wish
you luck with doing that I'm curious if
you'll let my guys stand up here and
then you you look at their boxing form
okay just tell me if you think anybody
is boxed before okay so this is Paulie
and then you know just like who would
make you nervous this new position feel
strong yes how long would it take you to
knock him out I said how much would it
take for you to get in the ring with you
and he said for $50,000 he'd get in the
ring and let you knock him out all
expenses and all players go okay all
right
fritzy come on up here now he's got big
arms here okay yeah don't let him fool
you
softball oh yeah how long do you think
it would last might be a little bit
couple seconds more because like
different wait oh he called you fat come
on in McLovin gobble balls yeah okay
okay all right what do you what do you
think about it this is a gentleman is it
all this old school is from UK probably
Jack Dempsey yeah
your physics or yeah you're from the
kingdom yeah
Seaton you want a piece of triple G here
what do you think well everybody's ready
you know Joe says I know just I have a
problem and they always see the style
isn't you're used to seeing a
professional style right but as somebody
ever got in the ring with you and you
went what are they doing like I like the
style looks different than you've ever
seen yes because some boxers have like
you know get in and be right-handed and
then the old box left like though change
up being in a fight right right does
that mess you up at all
you know just first couple second you
you look okay he strategy if he goes
back or going fraud you know like it's
something like okay show me your
strategy okay after couples take a
couple moments you know okay right now I
got it like that how much pride you take
in the fact that you've never touched
the canvas never been put down this is
good for me cause that sound like my
parents oh please please everybody like
my genetics like it said I don't miss
anybody you know just come back just
feel good if you feel good like feel
healthy it's more important for me for
my parents
how were they when they watch you fight
how's your mom when she wants you to uh
she can't she can't she doesn't know she
can know now and she can't watch TV she
you know she's like oh she gosh you're
going like eating walking's I don't
think you know anything but your dad's
okay yeah yeah yeah like you feel a
little bit nervous but that's your bear
yes nor one yeah that is normal
who's the toughest person in the family
[Music]
she's a boss yeah hey it's great to see
you and you're easy to root for I love
you
and I hope you get that chance to
finally put Canelo on his butt I hope so
yes thank you so much take care of
business on Saturday night
absolutely okay triple G you can see him
at Madison Square Garden also the zone
Daz and the app you can download that if
you can't go to the fight for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]